if you are one of those that was enraged
in the general election last year at the
rampant blatant bias of the BBC but are
now coming to the defense of the BBC now
that Boris Johnson is reviewing its
structure and Finance you are a mug the
BBC is based on a mid 20th century style
financial package which cannot possibly
be allowed to survive into the middle of
the 21st four billion pounds in licence
fees are extorted ruthlessly by the
British Broadcasting Corporation a state
broadcaster by a compulsory poll tax
paid on pain of imprisonment literally
going to jail if you don't pay it the
biggest number of women convicted of
criminal offences in Britain in 2019
were convicted of licence fee offences
they've got another billion pounds of
income on top of that either directly
from the government or from the sales of
products made by virtue of that public
expenditure in the first place so that's
five billion pounds a year all coming
from a compulsory poll tax which takes
no account of your ability to pay and
it's that kind of extraordinarily lavish
funding which accounts for the Cheshire
grin of God a line occur who gets 1.75
million pounds a year of your money to
present match of the day and he doesn't
even do that every week and he does many
other lucrative things to it also pays
for the sneering smut enos of graham
norton and a dozen 20 40 other rich
Nicholas Lee highly-paid so-called
celebrities who could never earn
anything like that in the private sector
and it's that kind of expenditure that
scale of expenditure which crushes new
talent crushes new innovative television
makers of programs because the monopoly
of the BBC is the deadly up a street
under which nothing else can grow as a
matter of fact the BBC are doing things
with your money that there is absolutely
no need at all for a state broadcaster
to do why do we need a state broadcaster
to make game shows or run pop record
radio stations these are things that
should be left to the market place where
they can be done much more efficiently
much more creatively and much more
cheaply to the customer many many
millions of people in Britain and I'm
one of them
are already paying subscriptions to
Netflix to Amazon to Manchester United
TV to Celtic TV to BT sports and we have
to pay all that money billions of pounds
to a state broadcaster and if we don't
we go to jail how can that possibly be a
model that survives in the 21st century
where people at the touch of a button
can pick and choose what they actually
want to watch and therefore what they
actually want to pay for as a state
broadcaster it is the guardian of the
prevailing orthodoxy so the political
orthodoxy of the day is ruthlessly
policed and patrolled by the BBC no one
with a contrary point of view would
survive five minutes as a presenter on
any level in the BBC and if they're
outside of the prevailing orthodoxy
pretty quickly they won't even be picked
to be interviewed or to appear on a
panel on question time
trust me on that I know it was a good
turn but it went on too long and became
too big too bloated to corrupt and too
arrogant in this day and age the BBC
will have to take its place in
competition with all other creators of
content on a level playing field and
will have to compete fairly there are
many ways that people can pay for the
things that the BBC which originally was
set up to do we can still have it if we
want to pay for David Attenborough or
you want to pay Gary Lineker is 1.7
million just to see them on match of the
day as a matter of fact other football
programs are available and even better
if you want BBC programmes you've only
got to scroll down on your remote
control and you can pay for them the BBC
has no place in most of the activities
that it is currently conducting once
upon a time the BBC was said to be in
possession of wreaths Ian values
whatever that means not even sure what
it meant at the time certainly doesn't
apply now it's time to lay a wreath on
the wreath Ian values of the BBC